so the director said make sure to show
it's an apple show so the viewer knows
the producers were a bunch of [ __ ]
okay let's get this out of the way nice
and early five preemptive sins for
calling soccer
football which i'm positive this show
will do at some point come on england
get your own language
do you want it it's a hockney must be
worth a
million pounds good point you should
have said yes
auction power please being a hock tees
mrs mannion
excuse me miss wilton if there is one
last name you must not
under any circumstances get wrong it's
the last name of your recently cheated
on and divorced boss
unless of course higgins himself is
looking to get divorced from his job
and or bollocks i love what you've done
to the place
did you do it yourself i'll get some to
help you i could ask the same of your
hair
please oh close but the answer we were
actually looking for was get out of my
office you homophobic piece of
one theodore ted lasso if the guy's name
is theodore and he goes by ted just call
him ted
since when do respected news agencies or
even espn for that matter useful names
for everyone
come on scottsworth vandenberg peltsmith
you're better than this
at first i was thinking about not
sleeping then i was thinking about
thinking about not sleeping that
that's never good what a coincidence
because i was just thinking about how
much jason sudeka sounds like he's doing
a foghorn lakehorn impression here
then i was thinking about thinking about
how much i think this is us right here
what are you sure the guy with the roll
commercial sign that says your name on
it is the guy you're looking for
my surprise hath overwhelmed me why is
ollie still awkwardly holding this
whiteboard with ted's name on it is he
worried the ted is going to forget he's
his ride
i know most of the world thinks
americans are done but jeez give us some
credit
we invented the chauffeur
i had no idea that in england the
sidewalk is meant for people
and cars what is this madness these
victorian era headmasters all they
wanted to do was
get the boys to stop masturbating so
they invented a sport where the boys
wouldn't use their hands at all
and they thought that might do the trick
this makes no sense as an
anti-masturbatory tactic
surely you want a sport that will keep
their hands occupied at the very least a
sport with a high risk of hand or groin
injury thereby making masturbation more
painful than it's worth
not sure if it worked but i can tell you
with absolute certainty and conviction
it did not is the coach looks out
longingly at the empty playing service
cliche international law now
seriously we get it they all want to
make weird stadium babies with their
sport just move on
could you take coach beard and get in
their ids housing information
you know anything they need wi-fi
password wet wipes wi-fi password and
wet wipes
damn it ted this is exactly why those
victorian wankers invented soccer in the
first place
how do you take your tea pollinated
preferably so this setup is perfect with
the drooping flowers dropping their
seasonal [ __ ] directly into the tea
where he looks like a good time that's
my ex-husband
well good times aren't always a good
time i've found no ted
good times are a good time and good
times that are not a good time are
called
bad times we good i'm so sorry i thought
you knew they're ready for you now
they're what pretending like this is a
soundproof door
ted would have been hearing that natter
chatter all the way down the hallway
hey if i don't need silence i'm going to
start punching
if silence is your goal i wouldn't
recommend starting your beating in the
pelvic area
speaking of which beating in the pelvic
area is exactly why they invented look
at this
english pubs are the og youtube comments
section and honestly for that they both
deserve a sin
nobody can understand you well if that
isn't the limey calling the kettle frog
i don't know what is we won the league
last year so the media devolves to
screaming out various questions which
builds tension just as the writers
intended but why would the journalist
want to play the what does he know game
at all
ted started off by saying you could fill
two internets with what i don't know
about football so
none of this should be a surprise
somewhere over the last few years we
seem to have abandoned our sense of
manners and hospitality could have been
while you were doing all that colonizing
totally understandable it was a busy
time for you now coach lasso may not
have a cv that you all find acceptable
cvs yes i know it's an english thing but
more and more i'm hearing americans use
cv instead of resume like it's some sort
of fancy word upgrade i bet you don't
even know what it stands for do you it
could stand for crusty vagina for all
you know yes i know it's latin
fine crustus vaginas my point is you
aren't too good for the word resume sean
we look forward to seeing you all at our
next match with crystal palace
cheese and pinch's crystal palace who do
they represent narnia
maybe fails miserably major premier
league
see my ex-husband truly loved only one
thing his entire life
this club and ted lasso is gonna help me
burn it to the ground
this seems like a lot of effort to exact
revenge on a cheating spouse wouldn't it
be quicker and easier to literally just
burn the club down if richmond is in the
premier league the worst that can happen
is they get demoted to a lower league
and that will take the entire season
it could take years before the team is
truly forced to close down
even if everything goes to plan and the
club is ruined forever that's hardly the
crowning achievement you would want to
add to your resume
is it that's right i said resume if you
don't like it you can shove it up your
cv
i want him to feel like he's been in the
ass with a splintered cricket bat i'd
recommend calling sarah michelle gellar
she has easy access to wooden stakes and
sure he's changed his last name but
buffy would certainly want to know if
rupert had strayed this far from the
path of good
uh though some people um pronounce it
jif and jod bless them for getting it
right
coach you try this
that does not come lightly from that
fill i'll tell you that but you continue
to impress nate
you remember i love these three it's
already evident they're absolutely
perfect together this is the funniest
threesome put on film since zoolander
and i'm taking a sin off
also that's right a sin removal also the
kindness and warmth of ted lasso is so
pure it makes even me want to be a
better person
i swear the opposite of an [ __ ]
should be a lasso like look at that
lasso over there getting over in traffic
so someone can pass
or did that entire line just let that
older man to the front so he could get
his food first put a bunch of lassos
holy smokes did you see that in what way
is this half backflip kick better than
catching the ball controlling it and
then shooting
yeah looks cool but isn't the point to
get the ball thingy inside the net
thingy
rumor has it if you say gridarius firmus
victoria three times while rubbing a
stamp and drinking a cup of tea the
queen of england herself will appear and
butter your crumpets i haven't tried it
myself because i'm not sure how much of
that is a metaphor
and frankly i don't know enough about
crumpets to confidently say if i want
mine buttered or not i do love a locker
room
smells like potential if ted lasso's
version of potential smells like the
sweat of 20 soccer players i'd hate to
know what his olfactory sense makes of
disappointment
oh yes stretch the computer cords from
the wall all the way to the center of
the room like a bunch of [ __ ]
although popular throughout the second
half of the 20th century the black and
white style soccer ball pictured here
hasn't been widely used in professional
or international soccer since 2006.
i respect this drawing a lot more if the
artist bothered to do their research
kids this inspirational quote has 29
words and not a single
comma breathe man breathe is this magnet
denoting something that is happening on
two concurrent fridays
if not it really should be all the way
in one friday or the other not
straddling this boundary as it currently
is
dammit people the lines are there for a
reason come on man don't be a sleep cop
script does not continue with sorry i
had a warrant out for your
arrest and that's a sin okay
gaffer tape you can see from this shot
that keeley's nipples are already
covered in this picture instead such a
prude that the entire mammary area has
to be concealed i love ted's heart but
this is keeley's call not his what you
doing back here where's jamie
oh he left his phone in his locker why
aren't he coming here he's still getting
waxed
surprisingly furry surprisingly furry
would also describe my internet browsing
history
all right that's it someone give me
whoever wrote this on the line
hello look here buddy how did how'd you
get a hold of my internet history
seems like such a nice manner i'm not
sure i can do this
my failed attempt at sending mr rogers
neighborhood somehow makes it into the
episode
i have it on good authority that gifting
a mushroom flavored pot noodle is an
ancient classical british tradition
which can be roughly interpreted as
you and the yankee horse you rode in on
this ted last solos on for some time
hey that'd be a full monday about
lightnington shouldn't be bright out in
there could anyone go up in the
[Music]
he's mountains the ball now the ball's
over there
that man has it now that's an
interesting development
maybe he'll kick the ball he has indeed
and apparently
that deserves a round of applause it's a
hockney must be worth a
million pounds 100 billion
dollars thanks if we see each other
in our dreams let's goof around a little
bit pretend like we don't know each
other
why don't you see what you can get up to
in five minutes
not a wink no my brain just kept on
cooking
that's a joke boy you missed it went
right past you you got to keep i say you
got to keep on your toes put toes that
is
the fast ones get right by you keep your
ears open yep
yep yep i can't get a word in edgeways
[Music]
get off my lawn our turn to look there's
a little kitty cat in our
in our kitchen so i said what are you
doing in here little kitty cat
by that time the cat go [ __ ] yourself
san diego
lynx my favorite of the jungle cats
it's made with bits of real panther so
you know it's good